more air power has been sent to fight
fires in southwest greece
the threat of them getting out of
control is growing here
with rising temperatures and
strengthening winds closing in
in the thick of this vast forest are the
british contingent
sent to greece to support the
international effort here
they invited us to join their mission
[Music]
undaunted by the scale of the task
before them in this smoldering forest
the humidity is really going to drop at
two o'clock is going to be about 16
and these hot spots that you can see
will start burning again so we need to
manage them now before they start
burning and the heat wave's getting more
intense getting more right obviously
that's the climate change we're getting
um heavier storms so again this site now
is on quite a steep slope so that crews
will be looking for landslide risk after
this because all the vegetation is being
taken off and they run off and these are
the sort of things we get in south wales
as well and that's why we have to move
forward to protect our communities the
team are highly trained specialists but
just 21 of them are responsible for a
huge area
[Music]
our drone gave them another perspective
of the dangers around them
they've already seen just how quickly
the fires can take hold and we just see
like white smoke coming out from behind
the trees and then we were told to kind
of move back a little bit
move back and literally within
minutes you'd seen just little flickers
of orange in between the undergrowth and
then within
seconds it literally engulfed the entire
side of where we were opposite side of
where we were sitting it's literally
seconds you have no time to to get out
as we were filming our drone detected a
fire threatening to block the road down
the mountain
we've been warned that it's at this
point in the middle of the day that
things can get very dangerous it's now
very hot around 40 degrees celsius and
the wind is coming in it's changed
direction it's in conditions like this
the fires can start and take hold very
quickly
the british team urged us to pull out to
safety it felt worrying leaving this
small unit to tend to a smoking forest
but they say they're getting smarter
better at dealing with wildfires
expecting far more of this work with
climate change
sally look with sky news in the
peloponnese greece